on peut pas résister un confinement
supplémentaires si vous recombiner
l'économie c'était du bon sens vous
accélérez évidemment les plans sociaux
les entreprises sont déjà à la limite
survie dans un certain nombre de
secteurs c'est même plus en dessous de
la limite de la survie donc on voit bien
que quelqu'un confinement c'est à ce
moment là la mort de l'économie et donc
la mort également sociale pour beaucoup
c'est des bataillons de chômeurs c'est
beaucoup de choses
donc il faut relancer aider à la relance
mais il faut pas brûler ses vaisseaux
pour le pour l'avenir tel qu'on ne peut
pas non plus dire qu'on est prêtes à
dépenser n'importe quel âge grand
n'importe quel volume d'argent pour
provoquer une relance qui à un moment
donné ce que tournera contre nous parce
qu'on roulera sur les bêtes là aussi
rétablir les finances publiques
après oui oui et moi j'entends ça tout
le temps je j'entends ça depuis toujours
il ya toujours une bonne raison il faut
quand même avoir en tête qu'on a abordé
cette liste dans une situation de
faiblesse
contrairement ce que que des
gouvernements situation de faiblesse sur
le plan du chômage situation de
faiblesse sur le plan de la dette
sur le plan des déficits etc et sur le
plan de la dépense donc les réformes
n'avaient pas été fait dans d'autres
pays on les a faites avant que le
gouvernement a toujours eu un plan
d'urgence de retard pour tout vous dire
on a fait beaucoup de propositions les
républicains ont fait beaucoup de
propositions dans ce plan d'urgence
beaucoup des propositions faites par les
républicains ont été reprises pas tout
donc je pense que la question n'est pas
de ceux de se chamailler sur le plan
politique la question elle est que ce
plan d'urgence qui doit être mise en
oeuvre
et ce plan de relance extrêmement
rapidement et ne doit pas être prétexte
ce que ça c'est un autre sujet il doit
pas être prétexte à empêcher tout type
ou tout autre type de réforme en france
la véritable relance le souhaitent oui
l'art il a mal à la vraie relance se
serait en réalité que la france soit
réformée dans d'autres pays a pas
d'énorme plan de relance juin des faits
se réformer